listening to film
courage women
and Kerry Wood
I was always a class clown I was always
getting detention or you know but if I
can if I could give a good joke if I get
the whole class left and detention was
worth it cuz I got a good laugh and then
all the jobs I had people always say you
know are you an actor are you were
comedian or this and you that so the
sign why don't I love acting you know
it's so fun to put on other people's
shoes I mean how many times have you
like thought you watch moon like damn I
wish I could do that or you hear a great
story on the news or you know some
heroic thing or some ugly thing or you
know you watch a vampire film like my ID
led to be a vampire they've got their
turn to a bat and go bite some fine
on the neck you know it's like you
know I mean it's like it's fine man it's
pretend and you know you go out and do
these things and you don't go to jail or
none of this stuff anything you get
accolades and get accolades to be a bad
guy or a good guy you know if you want
to do it's just and also the research
elements to I really enjoy getting into
these roles so much so that uh it
oftentimes affects my personal life but
I really enjoy getting lost in these
characters in discovering things about
them and feet whether it's because it's
a from a historical period or just
creating some kind of just trying to be
innovative and create something new and
different and still fit the peace and
the care can be an honest and truthful
to it